c'est lors de notre second débat tout de
suite dans notre émission comme tous les
jeudis gros plan sur un thème de
campagne et les propositions des
candidats des candidats devant des
programmes
demandé programme consacré au nucléaire
alors que les prix de l'énergie
notamment de l'électricité flambe le
débat est au coeur de cette campagne
présidentielle tous les camps affichent
leurs idées et rares sont ceux qui
veulent fermer nos centrales mariant
dépêche
58% des français sont favorables à la
sortie du nucléaire selon un sondage
ifop paru aujourd'hui un chiffre qui va
à l'encontre des dernières prises de
position du chef de l'état notre avenir
énergétique écologique passe par le
nucléaire pourvu que l'on progresse sur
la gestion des déchets
sur la sûreté et je vous sais là aussi
pleinement mobilisé l'énergie nucléaire
est une énergie décarbonée une énergie
sûre ligne pro-nucléaire également pour
la candidate est républicain valérie
pécresse elle défend la construction de
6 nouveaux réacteurs et en
investissement massif dans la recherche
on peut pas avec les prix atteignent
aujourd'hui toutes les énergies fossiles
se priver d'une énergie à bas coût qui
est une filière industrielle
d'excellence française marine le pen
fustige la souveraineté européenne
défendue selon elle par les jumeaux
macron pécresse et prône la sortie du
marché européen de l'énergie qu'elle
estime d'une absurdité totale au lieu de
s'inspirer du modèle énergétique
français propre et bon marché fondée sur
le nucléaire et l'hydroélectricité
bruxelles a été le bras armé de
l'allemagne pour affaiblir cet avantage
compétitif français lors de son
déplacement la semaine dernière dans les
côtes d'armor la candidate s'est
également opposés aux éoliennes un
programme très similaire à celui du
candidat eric zemmour je vous rappelle
que monsieur macro quand il est arrivé
au pouvoir a annoncé la suppression de
12 réacteurs donc il faut il faut
renoncer évidemment cette suppression il
faut en créer 14 il faut prolonger la
durée de vie des réacteurs nucléaires à
60 ans et parce que ça ne suffira est-ce
que vous éradiquer les éoliennes jeu
n'éradique pas mais je n'en construit
plus à gauche de l'échiquier politique
l'insoumis jean luc mélenchon plaide
pour une sortie du nucléaire comme il
rappelé lors de son meeting mais nous
avons besoin d'en sortir parce que le
danger est immense alors comment eh bien
oui il y aura des éoliennes offshore
oui il y aura des machines houlomotrices
on sait les faire sortie du nucléaire
aussi pour le candidat écologiste
yannick jadot qui s'est directement
adressée à emmanuel macron hier au
parlement européen vous promouvez le gaz
ont sauvé un nucléaire condamnés à la
faillite et vous sacrifiez faisant
l'ambition climatique de l'europe enfin
pour la candidate du parti socialiste
anne hidalgo objectif 100 % renouvelable
et une sortie du nucléaire non
précipitée horizon 2050
devant des programmes sur le nucléaire
vous l'avez vu au coeur de cette
campagne présidentielle
j'accueille deux anciennes ministres de
l'écologie des films bateau françois
vincent être députée des deux-sèvres
porte-parole de yannick jadot et vous
avez été ministre pendant le quinquennat
de françois hollande chantal jouanno
bonsoir le présidente de la commission
nationale du débat public vous nous la
présenter parce que tout le monde je
pense ne la connais pas et vous étiez
ministre à l'époque de nicolas sarkozy
gérard longuet bonsoir soit l'ancien
ministre est également mais pas de
l'écologie vous êtes cb de l'industrie
mais de l'industrie donc ça se rapproche
évidemment et vous êtes sénateur et
l'air de la meuse vous avez co signé
récemment une lettre adressée au chef de
l'état pour défendre l'avenir une
financement de la filière nucléaire au
niveau européen avec les nouvelles
règles de ce que l'on appelle la
taxonomie verte j'accueille également en
visioconférence yves marignac et chef du
pôle énergie nucléaire et fossiles de
l'association mégawatts bonsoir à vous
bienvenus laetitia même pas évidemment
il rester à mes côtés je rappelle
l'objectif objectif neutralité carbone
pour la france en 2050 est ce que pour
atteindre cet objectif on peut se passer
du nucléaire delphine batho
alors en fait
le nucléaire c'est l'espèce de totem
qui cache un tabou le tabou c'est que
pour
réagir et agir comme il faut face à
l'urgence climatique il faut diminuer
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
50 5% avant 2030 et que donc en fait la
centralité si vous voulez du débat sur
le nucléaire sur lequel on va discuter
ensuite mais je tiens à être clair sur
la vision dans laquelle je m'inscris
occultes la première urgence est la
première urgence est de diviser par deux
notre consommation d'énergie en france
la sobriété absolument mais c'est aussi
un gain excusez moi pour le pouvoir de
vivre au moment où les factures
d'énergie explose et où les entreprises
aussi sont confrontés à l'augmentation
du prix de l'énergie donc il faut
d'abord investir massivement dans les
économies d'énergie la deuxième priorité
absolue c'est de sortir des énergies
fossiles et en fait c'est important on
va parler du nucléaire et de rappeler
que la première
énergie consommée en france ce sont des
énergies fossiles c'est du pétrole que
quand on parle du nucléaire on ne parle
que de l'électricité parce que sinon en
fait on est dans une situation beaucoup
de français croient que la première
énergie en consommer en france c'est du
nucléaire eh bien non troisièmement il
faut aller vers un modèle 100%
renouvelable de façon responsable donc
telle échéance au gré s'il est la
première décision à prendre est de ne
pas lancer en france un nouveau
programme nucléaire comme veut le faire
emmanuel macron sans aucun débat
démocratique et ce qui est une hérésie à
la fois par rapport au calendrier de
l'action pour le climat parce qu'en fait
les réacteurs dont on parle c'est 2045
2050 dont sais c'est pas dans le
calendrier de 2030 elle je vous le
disais deuxièmement ce n'est plus
compétitive sur le plan économique et
troisièmement c'est une énergie qui
comporte des risques et donc en fait le
problème du nucléaire ne s'appréhende
pas seulement sur dans une problématique
si vous voulez du bilan carbone mais
aussi des risques j'aime la société et
de la sûreté nucléaire gérard longuet
vous n'êtes pas sur cette ligne-là vous
pensé au contraire qu'il faut relancer
l'énergie la filière nucléaire en france
oui totalement je suis d'accord avec
madame bateau sur un point c'est que il
ya une urgence à décarbonés et qu'à
partir du moment où chacun reconnaît que
c'est une urgence ce qui nous vaut
d'ailleurs ça fait cinq six ans moment
que le monde en est convaincu
il faut utiliser les moyens alors je
suis là aussi d'accord sur un deuxième
point c'est que pour l'instant
l'électricité ne traite pas de la
mobilité et traite partiellement du
chauffage et de l'industrie
simplement pour traiter de la mobilité
il faut des batteries pour avoir des
voitures électriques ou de l'hydrogène
pour avoir des piles à combustible qui
fonctionne sur des poids lourds ou
peut-être de l'hydrogène utilisé
directement sur l'industrie et si l'on
veut une hydrogène massive il faut du
nucléaire il faut du nucléaire parce que
c'est la façon
charger les batteries et c'est la façon
de produire par électrolyse de
l'hydrogène qui soit sinon verte du
moins ne produisons pas de co2 dont nous
sommes tenus non seulement de maintenir
notre parc pour les fonctions actuelles
mais entre la mobilité l'hydrogène pour
l'industrie et j'ajoute le numérique est
un énorme console est ce que votre
réflexion sur l'économie est plein de
bon sens chez toujours éteint la lumière
quand j'ai quitté une pièce j'ai appris
de ma maman et j'en suis très très
heureux mais s'agit pas du tout parce
que avec le numérique vous avez une
consommation que vous ne pourrez pas
limité avec l'intelligence artificielle
vous avez des besoins de stockage
considérable donc et le renouvelable
lorsqu'il est aléatoire ce qui est le
cas de l'éolien et du solaire
l'électricité ne se stockant pas il faut
absolument du nucléaire on a bien vous
avez posées
ils ont l'occasion de deux de répondre
et macro et de votre avis oui bon
j'aimerais qu'il en tire des concessions
chantal jouanno deux questions d'une
peut-être une présentation de de la
commission nationale du débat public en
quelques mots et puis ensuite quand vous
faites parce que votre votre rôle c'est
de faire dialoguer finalement autour des
projets de projets d'investissements
lourds 1 quand vous avez des pros des
antinucléaires est-ce que vous
réussissez à les faire dialoguer deux
questions en une deux questions en une
alors la commission nationale du débat
public c'est une autorité qui existe
depuis 25 ans et qui a pour mission
justement d'organiser des débats publics
c'est-à-dire d'informer le public sur
l'existence d'un projet et lui permettre
d'en débattre mais pour peser sur la
décision le plus en amont possible à un
moment où on envisage le projet et de le
faire avec toutes les garanties de
neutralité et d'indépendance donc ça
c'est vraiment notre mission et on le
fait dans le domaine de l'environnement
donc bien évidemment le nucléaire a été
un des sur des gros projets quel montant
j'espère que le seuil obligatoire de
saisine c'est minimum 300 millions
d'euros on peut être saisi sur des plus
petits projets et c'est minimum 300
millions d'euros alors le nucléaire on
est à peu près tout le temps évidemment
danser danser seul et alors ce dialogue
alors ce dialogue ça fait 17 ans un
premier débat ça fait 17 ans on en a
fait plus d'une dizaine sur des gros
projets nucléaires on y arrive on y
arrive on arrive à mettre des très très
pourri des très très contre autour d'une
table et à dialoguer sous réserve que
vraiment il ya une condition qu'ils
soient respectés c'est qu'aucune
décision ne soit prise avant ou comment
le public n'ait pas le sentiment que
c'est un débat déjà été des succès a
déjà été décidé et puis le deuxième
élément évidemment c'est on l'a vue là
c'est passionnant c'est un vrai énorme
débat de société c'est à dire quand
derrière le nucléaire faut d'abord
parler de la politique climatique et de
la politique énergétique pour monter en
amont et derrière ça quel mode de vie on
veut demain quel modèle de société on
veut demain donc c'est un très beau
magnifique débats de société
yves marignac âgées 10 mégawatts sénégal
a tonné le trésor c'est sûr par les
auteurs avérés par dollar de 1 sur les
connaît pardon de ceux de ce lapsus est
effectivement un enjeu sociétal je vais
reprendre le terme conques ont évoqué
tout à l'heure avec des films bateau
cette idée de sobriété vous vous trouvez
que le débat sur le nucléaire quoi il
ils occultent cette question centrale de
notre consommation d'électricité et
d'énergie en tout cas certains acteurs
servent effectivement du paravent
nucléaire pour occulter cette question
majeure est pour reprendre des éléments
dont a parlé monsieur longuet qui a
évoqué le développement du véhicule
électrique ou le développement du
numérique sur des enjeux comme celui là
on a non seulement la question
de la consommation d'énergie et des gaz
à effet de serre mais on a aussi la
question des matières premières des
métaux critiques et en fait l'ensemble
des limites auxquelles on est confronté
aujourd'hui il faut y ajouter bien sûr
la question cruciale de la biodiversité
nous oblige à réduire notre empreinte à
réduire notre consommation globale de
ressources et donc nous oblige à prendre
en compte avant toute chose cette
question de la sobriété et de
l'efficacité et donc ça c'est un enjeu
premier avant de parler effectivement du
choix sur ce qu'on appelle le mix
énergétique et qu'on réduit souvent la
question électrique en opposant le
nucléaire d'un côté et les énergies
renouvelables de l'autre mais la
deuxième dimension qui a déjà été évoqué
c'est que effectivement le nucléaire
apporte avec lui un certain nombre
d'enjeux un certain nombre de risques le
risque d'accident majeur le risque lié à
l'accumulation de déchets et au
transfert intergénérationnel est par
exemple quand on parle de relancer un
programme de réacteur il faut bien
projeté que ça veut dire d'avoir des
nouveaux pères qui fonctionne
pratiquement jusqu'à la fin du siècle
d'avoir encore un siècle de plus
derrière pour gérer les déchets issus de
ces réacteurs et donc ça veut dire qu'on
projette pour la société le fait qu'elle
reste institutionnellement
financièrement en capacité de gérer un
enjeu comme celui là sur un temps très
long donc c'est un vrai un vrai pari
pour l'avenir une vraie question
vis-à-vis des enjeux de soutenabilité
pour les générations futures donc oui
non seulement la question de la
stratégie climatique et premières et
donc pas constituer un débat mais les
enjeux liés au nucléaire en tant que tel
à la manière dont ils structurent la
société les questions institutionnelles
et démocratiques sont tout autant un
objet de débat je voudrais juste finira
par un point quand monsieur longuet 10
pour faire de l'hydrogène massif ou de
l'électricité va ciment il faut du
nucléaire c'est un argument d'autorité
qui en fait la plus cours aujourd'hui
j'en veux pour preuve les scénarios
publiée en octobre par rte qui a montrée
justement que des alternatives sont
possibles et que le choix entre
tout renouvelable ou une reconduction
partielle du programme nucléaire est
possible quel que soit d'une certaine
manière le niveau d'électricité dans
lequel on se projette la longue amont de
réponse et ensuite des films répond tout
simplement la l'étude de rte serait
magnifique si elle au 'business' il
n'avait pas gommer le fait que le
renouvelable et aléatoire et que la
l'acceptation l'acceptabilité chez
chantal jouanno des éoliennes et des
panneaux photovoltaïques connaît assez
rapidement c'est débite des films bateau
cc on est sur un vrai enjeu de société
la campagne présidentielle c'est
peut-être le meilleur moment pour les
enfants avons acheté eux n'a pas du tout
occulté les questions relatives aux
militants il y avait six scénarios ou
scénarii dit oui c'est ça mais il y
avait du nucléaire dans quasiment tous
les scénarios si je ne me trompe non il
ya un scénario sont présents
moi j'ai dit quasiment j'ai dit mario
100% renouvelable et laisser entrer cinq
sûr si on veut entrer dans les détails
techniques les scénarios avec du nouveau
nucléaire
occulte la réalité du réchauffement
climatique s'il faut faire des critiques
sur rtl et se base sur un niveau des
fleuves des rivières etc pour le
refroidissement des réacteurs qui sera
celui de 2050 et non pas celui de 2080
or il ya une réalité qui s'appelle le
changement climatique je ferme la
parenthèse oui mais c'est intéressant ce
qu'il disait gérard longuet sur
l'acceptabilité des
dg énergie et du renouvelable mais on
pourra poser la question aussi
d'éventuelles nouvelles centrales
nucléaires l'accessibilité c'est un
débat je voudrais qu'on parle du des
choses sérieuses les messieurs c'est
sérieux parce que quand on est riverain
d'un projet de parc éolien pas pardon et
chantage au loup peut en témoigner je
vais très sérieux je suis élu d'un
territoire rural qui est très concerné
par le développement parfois intempestif
de l'éolien donc je connais bien le
sujet lui ce que je veux c'est qu'on
parle des choses qui sont structurantes
et d'une vision structurants il n'y a
aucun chemin pour aboutir à la
neutralité carbone pour divise réduire
drastiquement nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre qui ne commence pas par
diviser par deux la consommation
d'énergie ensuite dans cette
consommation d'énergie on peut discuter
de est ce que c'est de l'électricité est
ce que c'est de la chaleur renouvelable
6 et de l'électricité renouvelable quels
types de renouvelables ont favorisé
comment mais il ya d'abord un principe
de réalité et donc comment au fait ce qu
tu es au moins fait pour nous car ici on
television pause
on investit massivement dans les
économies d'énergie dans la rénovation
des logements par exemple aujourd'hui on
a des millions de ménages qui sont en
situation de précarité énergétique c'est
pas normal et donc ça c'est la première
priorité ensuite sur le nucléaire il ya
en réalité deux discussions il ya le
débat sur faut-il un nouveau parc
nucléaire là nous nous disons non il ya
une deuxième discussion qui est de
savoir à quel rythme on peut diminuer le
parc nucléaire actuel et je pense c'est
important d'y voir clair dans les sujets
que les français vont devoir trancher
par leurs votes au mois d'avril et
justement c'est intéressant parce que
quand on vous écoute on a envie de
choisir notre modèle ce modèle si
vertueux et je me pose la question du
pourquoi ce modèle que vous proposez ne
s'impose pas dans le débat public et
j'en veux pour preuve je continue deux
enquêtes menées par bba pour aura nos
qui est une multinationale un qui est
spécialisée dans les métiers du
nucléaire je vous vois sourire c'est pas
déjà je n'en sais pas les français se
souviennent du nom areva
qui n'existe plus et 2010 et framatome
première grande enquête 2019 et deuxième
édition en octobre là il y a vraiment un
revirement de l'opinion publique mais
qui n'est pas en votre faveur je pose la
question de pourquoi je vais juste
exploser les chiffres par exemple 15 %
uniquement des français identifient le
nucléaire comme un handicap ils étaient
34 % en 2010 9 50% des français pensent
que c'est un atout pour le pays + 3 %
par rapport à 2010 9 53 % considèrent
que le nucléaire était essentielle pour
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
+7 % c'est-à-dire que l'érosion de
l'opinion publique qui serait contre le
nucléaire est en marche voyez ce que je
veux dire dont on a en fait basculer
l'opinion publique qui était quand même
parce qu'il y avait ces risques sur les
déchets sur les accidents nucléaires est
sacrée c'est vrai ce sentiment de peur
finalement ça s'est retourné est ce que
le récit médiatique qui est fait du
claire a une influence sur le
retournement de l'opinion publique c'est
à dire que dans les médias il ya quand
même une doxa qui nous explique de façon
assez majoritaire que grâce au nucléaire
nous avons moins de co2 dans l'air et
que donc c'est une énergie qui
permettent de décarbonés notre
production d'énergie mais est ce que
thomas sa infuse vraiment dans l'esprit
des français eh bien écoutez non puisque
nous sommes en 2000 21 octobre 58 % des
français pensent que le nucléaire
produit du co2 et a un impact sur le
climat ils étaient 60 9% en 2019 donc en
termes de connaissances et de perception
du nucléaire or le modèle que vous
proposez vous le proposer aux français
vous voyez en fait il ya une dichotomie
entre ce modèle vertueux et l'état de
connaissance en tout cas et de
perception des français pour adhérer à
trouver que le débat public doit être
poursuivi
la présidente je ne partage pas les
idées de monsieur jadot mais je suis
enchantée qu'il y ait ce débat un sujet
particulier
pour lequel je respect pour ses
convictions et la continuité second
fiction ce qui est déjà une qualité mais
comment expliquer aux gens qu'ils
doivent diminuer de moitié leur
consommation d'énergie alors que comme
un ajustement vous êtes représentante
d'un territoire rural à faible densité
de population où l' usage du véhicule
quelle que soit sa motricité est
absolument
ça ferait plaisir de terminer oui mais
comme je suis très courtois je laisse
les dames qui mon côté vieux vieux jeu
en quelque sorte alors oui j'ai pas dis
c'est aux gens de diviser par deux leur
consommation d'énergie et j'ai dit
l'état doit investir 10 milliards
d'euros pour jeunes et plus dans les
deux sèvres des familles qui ne se
chauffent pas l'hiver oui parce que je
comprenne bien et qui est maintenant il
ya l'idée de la décroissance l'idée de
la diminution est l'idée de l'autorité
une autorité politique qui demanderait
aux entreprises et au foyer de diminuer
leur consommation
dans quelle logique c'est exactement ce
qui est demandé notamment par
l'excellent représentants de négawatt
mais au moins le mérite de la franchise
il va au bout de votre solution il est
autoritaire la vôtre ne l'est pas
officiellement elle ne deviendrai
nécessairement parce que prenons par
exemple l'histoire des logements
l'électricité est sans doute la façon la
plus intelligente de remplacer le fioul
le gaz qui est livrée par an citerne
dans deux territoires ruraux parce que
les les pompes à chaleur permettent de
chauffer en économisant les deux tiers
de l'électricité allaient qu'était et
delphine batho qui ensuite évidemment
les et ce n'est pas la réaction
s'appelle le réchauffement
donc à des croissances et au milieu il
ya un truc qui s'appelle le
réchauffement climatique donc on peut
faire comme ses
confrères vous avez cet après-midi dans
le figurerait dans le figaro la carte de
france des villes qui vont être rayés de
la carte par la montée des océans donc
en fait on peut faire comme si le
pénible à plaisanterie à l'échelle
humaine on peut faire comme si c'est une
aimable sinueux et comme c'est une
aimable plaisanterie qu est ce qu est
une aimable plaisanterie en mai chez les
socios ne permettra pas de disparition
de la rochelle je suis désolé bain de
calaisis part de calais siboney la
comprenait les cartes en 2100 prenez les
cajas que l'est la montée d'ici la fin
du siècle c'est planait dans d'autres le
club dans l'aveyron que 1000 dans
quelques millimètres qui finissent par
faire des centimètres allez jo et je
vais être je reviens vers yves marignac
est ce que votre
votre modèle et autoritaire et des
croissants pour reprendre en quelque
sorte les
mots zhang et bien et m'a pas du tout et
c'est cette façon de caricaturer de
dénaturer
les politiques de maîtrise de la demande
qui inclut la sobriété et l'efficacité
c'est précisément ce qu'on disait au
départ c'est la la la la version qu'on
un certain nombre de tenant aujourd'hui
du statu quo nucléaire pour les leviers
qui sont aujourd'hui les leviers premier
de des stratégies de soutenabilité et
c'est pas que l'association négawatt qui
le dit c'est une convergence des experts
et les scénarios pour dire que la
maîtrise de la demande est effectivement
un incontournable sauf à faire des paris
technologique absolument absolument
délirant de l'atteinte des objectifs
climatiques et des objectifs de
réduction de notre empreinte cette
sobriété cette efficacité ça doit
évidemment pas être quelque chose deux
contre un et d'autoritaire c'est une
intelligence des usages une offre de
sobriété c'est à dire une régulation par
les pouvoirs publics pour créer des
alternatives à la voiture dont
effectivement les gens sont de plus en
plus dépendants à cause notamment d'une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
qui a rendu la voiture indispensable
pour couvrir des distances de plus en
plus grande et les territoires ruraux
évidemment en sont les premières
victimes donc inversés ce type de prix
de deux politiques
mettre en place des conditions
favorables pour qu'effectivement
les gens puissent consommer moins et
consommer mieux et voilà tous les
scénarios et négawatt le premier montre
qu' il ya en réalité énormément de kobe
néfice derrière derrière ces options si
vous permettez je voudrais au delà de ça
réagir à
propos sur l'opinion publique
l'opinion publique elle est aujourd'hui
prisonnière d'une
structure du débat où il ya deux
déterminants importants le premier c'est
que on ne parle effectivement plus que
d'énergie que sous l'angle du climat et
donc de nucléaire que sous l'angle du
crime a donc d'un nucléaire qui est
extrêmement désincarné par rapport aux
enjeux qu'on évoquait de risque de
déchets de politique industrielle de
perte de compétences industrielles
notamment la deuxième chose c'est que on
reste aussi dans la structure politique
de ces débats prisonnier de l'héritage
de justement la période glorieuse de
développement du nucléaire et de
développement aussi du service public du
monopole edf et voilà on a aujourd'hui
du mal à repenser la question de
l'énergie qu'il sait sur le nucléaire
enfin je veux dire il ya un moment il
faut arrêter aussi de dire ah bah oui
mais ça c'est l'héritage on a enfermé
madame vous êtes ici vous avez un mot
devient devait poser après il fut
cruelle effectivement les moyens pour
faire adhérer à votre projet le plus
grand dit pourquoi yannick jadot dépasse
pas les 10% grosso modo
dans notre habitat invités à une autre
émission je reviendrai avec plaisir à et
il a montré hier sa pugnacité notamment
chance au président de la république
mais juste sur la question de l'opinion
et après je pense que oui parce que
chantal jouanno a atteint par les plombs
deux choses la première c'est qu'en fait
il est très important d'expliquer qu'on
n'est pas dans la situation des années
70 dans les années 70 on est dans la
situation où il ya soit les énergies
fossiles soit le nucléaire aujourd'hui
il ya soit les énergies fossiles soit
les renouvelables donc c'est un
changement fondamental
la deuxième c'est qu'aujourd'hui en fait
on a dix réacteurs à l'arrêt on a cinq
réacteurs qui sont arrêtés pour des
raisons de sûreté et qu'en fait les
difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui sur les
prix de l'électricité sont liées au fait
que pour la france mais tous les oeufs
dans le même panier du nucléaire c'est
pas sûr c'est une vulnérabilité en fait
et voilà aujourd'hui nous allons vous
avez d entreprise
européen de l'électricité qui a indexé
sur le gaz mais aussi le fait que vous
voyez encore planté aborder sans âge là
nous moi ce que je retiens
c'est l'importance d'organiser
finalement un débat public c'est ce que
cette campagne présidentielle sert à ça
le niveau grâce inouïe nam et si nous la
donnent aux émissions donnent la parole
est on est on essaye d'exprimer vos
l'aller les subtilités programmes des
uns et des autres mais là vous dites
qu'ils ont tant l'opinion puissants
n'ont pas une politique et la campagne
des présidentielles effectivement à un
moment de positionnement très important
il faut quand même un peu donner la
vérité des prix au français est là et la
réalité de fonds en leur donner le temps
de s'informer
de manière objective avec tous les
arguments et un super rapport de la cour
des comptes que je vous avis toutes et
tous à lire de mi novembre qui dit
grosso modo on est incapable de tenir
les objectifs qu'on s'est fixés dans les
délais fixés dans les prix fixés en tout
cas sur la partie du nucléaire et ce
rapport dit il faut un débat
démocratique mais un débat objectif
apaisé parce que effectivement on peut
dire bah regardez aujourd'hui les
français sont un peu plus pour le
nucléaire le 50 50 il a été historique y
varie un peu plus un peu moins quand on
fait du débat public qu'on va sur le
terrain qu'on va aller parler de
flamanville où de penly on n'a plus du
tout même discours face à face à soi
donc ce débat est aujourd'hui il doit
avoir lieu et on doit le replacer dans
la politique énergétique effectivement
est-ce qu'on divise par 2 ou pas et ça
ça impacte les modes de vie au quotidien
et le nucléaire est un des éléments du
mix énergétique parce que sur les
énergies renouvelables je vous écoutait
mais nous on fait tous les débats
publics sur l'éolien en mer on a fait 14
aujourd'hui les gens nous disent grosso
modo le discours majoritaire c'est mon
époux on a ils ont un problème avec
l'éolien en mer il ya quelques uns qui
sont opposés et c'est souvent un jeu des
antinucléaires
oui oui ça ils s'opposent de ce côté là
oui mais enfin quand on fait du débat
public justement l'intérêt c'est qu'on
va voir le grand public mais nous disent
bon si vous pouvez les mettre plus loin
c'est bien et en mal effectivement donc
voilà ce qu'ils nous disent donc sur le
renouvelable attention il ne faut pas
mettre tous les oeufs peints faut pas
dire que tout le monde est content le
renouvelable c'est quand on est sur le
nia dessablement des grès 70 on ne peut
pas tout faire avec des renouvelables
mais les français ils sont trés il faut
la refaire compte davantage
pardonnez moi c'est d'avoir une
concentration des lieux de production
chez complètement d'accord avec l'idée
qu'on ne fera pas de centre a c'est
aussi un acompte et les territoires les
territoires qui sont équipés centrale
souhaite les garder
vous êtes dubitative j'ai foi les débats
de kwajalein
nécessitant alors on s'était manifesté
alors je dis c'est le moment oui on n'a
pas eu ce débat pour messmer ces moments
de faire maintenant c'est vrai c'est le
moment et
donc ça veut dire après le résultat de
la présidentielle pour vous il faudra
que le ou la présidente participent à un
débat
un grand débat public sur les appelle le
parlement oui il ya quand même quelques
gestes
sénat
sur les grandes orientations je ne
partage pas le point de vue de je me
répète de madame bateau et respect je ne
partage pas mais il ya un lieu où on
débat l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
et lorsque c'est du domaine législatif
et hemani mais là on a un outil de
démocratie participative peut
fonctionner
vous n'avez pas vocation et vous le
savez a remplacé le législateur bien des
vocations est plus faible évolution dans
le fonctionnement
moins d'électeurs et parce que les
électeurs aux sentiments leurs
parlementaires n'ont plus de pouvoir ce
qui est hélas vrai bon et moi je préfère
les électeurs le parlement et parce que
le débat public est née entre admirable
pour des projets ponctuels pour une
politique d'ensemble durable dans le
temps je ne
les question vous pensez qu'il faut pas
débat public sur la politique nucléaire
parce que ces jeunes lorsque le débat
public appartient au parlement en la
matière sauf à faire le saut vers les
années 70-80 n'a jamais été débattue au
parlement fait via d'heure il ya des
sujets majeurs de notre pays qui n'ont
jamais été débattue au parlement et sont
en général sur les piges et et qui
génère des frustrations je reprends la
main parce qu'on va faire un gros plan
pour terminer sur ce que le président de
la république avait annoncé c'est smr
pour small modular lui hector laurent
mauriac vous êtes le rédacteur en chef
de brief milk est partenaire de nos
débats du jeudi dans science publique
bonsoir bienvenue fortement
le président qui est mise donc sur ces
petits réacteurs en effet emmanuel
macron doit encore préciser les grands
axes de ses projets en matière nucléaire
mais il a déjà mis l'accent sur une
piste de développement les smr les
petits réacteur modulaire et voici ce
qu'il disait en octobre lors d'un
discours sur l'innovation nous devons
absolument nous préparer à des
technologies de rupture et
transformations profondes sur le
nucléaire la promesse de ce qu'on
appelle les small modula reactors qui
sont les petits réacteurs beaucoup plus
modulaire est beaucoup plus sûr parce
que la sûreté est un point clé du débat
sur le nucléaire alors en quoi
consistent ces réacteurs alors le terme
désigne une famille de réacteurs qui
peuvent fonctionner avec des
technologies différentes mais qui ont
plusieurs points communs tout d'abord
ils sont plus petits que les réacteurs
classiques et au moins de puissance
ensuite ils peuvent être fabriqués en
série puis transporté en pièces
détachées et assemblées sur le site
finale enfin sur l'aspect de la sécurité
comme ils sont plus petits le risque est
limité pour chaque smr mais comme on a
besoin de plus de réacteurs pour
atteindre une même puissance on peut
aussi considérer que ce risque est
démultipliée est-ce qu'ils existent déjà
quelque part alors un opérateur russe à
installer une mini centrale dans une
ville en sibérie et la présente comme un
smr c'est une centrale flottante qui
repose sur une barge et à ce jour il n'y
en a pas d'autres en activité il existe
aujourd'hui 72 projets dans le monde
après la russie
ce sont la chine et les etats unis qui
sont les pays les plus avancés la france
n'est pas en avance elle n'a qu'un seul
projet en cours qui s'appelle new world
c'est un projet mené par un consortium
auquel appartient edf la construction
d'un démonstrateur est prévue en 2030
est-ce que c'est éphémère serait adapté
au marché français alors il faut savoir
que le projet new world n'est pas
destiné au marché français mais à
l'export comme les nerfs sont moins
puissants que les réacteurs classiques
ils sont surtout adapté à des cas
particuliers alors ça peut être des
lieux isolés ça peut être aussi des
lieux très énergivores comme des mines
ou des sites industriels et puis les smr
sont aussi adaptés pour remplacer des
centrales à charbon parce que leur
puissance est similaire et que ces
centrales sont déjà équipés deux lignes
haute tension en sortie donc c'est
intéressant pour des pays qui ont encore
beaucoup de centrales à charbon comme
les états unis la chine ou l'allemagne
dans le réseau français les smr pourrait
être utilisé pour alimenter des sites
industriels pour le chauffage urbain ou
pour en complément des grandes centrales
au final on peut dire qu'il reste encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur l' usage des
smr sur leurs coûts et sur leur
technologie et il faudra lever ces
incertitudes avant de pouvoir en faire
un relais de croissance pour l'industrie
nucléaire française merci laurent
laurent mauriac le rédacteur en chef de
brief me briefing diffusée chaque soir
qui résume qui explique que l'actualité
en dix minutes vous avez l'essentiel
c'est sûr applis mobiles et sur et par
e-mail des films bateau quand vous avez
entendu le présent la république lancé
sa set cette idée comment vous avez
réagi parce que ça nous engage là aussi
on est dans la même logique ça nous
engage potentiellement pour des
décennies et des décennies c'est un
écran de fumée vraiment je ne sais plus
comment le dire sérieusement ce qui
compte c'est ce qu'on fait entre
maintenant et 2030 donc en fait d'agiter
des sujets de recherche technologique
sur des choses qui n'existent pas
aujourd'hui en termes industriels n'est
pas sérieux par rapport à l'urgence dans
laquelle nous sommes
par ailleurs sur une zone
devait de mettre de l'intelligence ou
sur ces questions là sur le net donc
réparer les réacteurs de dollars dont
raison mais si on parle de choix
politique le choix politiques chat peut
être qu'on choisit le nucléaire et donc
on prépare l'avenir avec les réacteurs
de demain si je vous dis que vous
souffrez d'indigestion et que je vous
prescrit un médicament pour une autre
maladie et dont beaucoup plus longtemps
vous allez rigoler en fait vous allez
dire ce n'est pas sérieux donc là en
fait on souffre du réchauffement
climatique et on souffre d'une politique
énergétique qui est en train de situer
de créer partout en europe une situation
catastrophique du point de vue
économique du point de vue du pouvoir de
vivre des gens et du point de vue des
entreprises est qui et qui nous creuse
le déficit de la balance commerciale
avec les importations d'énergie fossile
donc soyons sérieux minutes parlons des
choses qui existent et ensuite ce
qu'emmanuel mac on veut faire sans débat
démocratique et pour vous mettre
d'accord tous les deux ni au parlement
ni avec les citoyens par le débat public
c'est le fait de la présidence est telle
qu'elle est vécue avec le cac va lancer
un nouveau programme nucléaire ep est
donc il n'a rien à voir avec les petits
réacteurs ceinture soit disant dont il
est question et qu'en fait il y a une
politique du fait accompli sur ce
nouveau programme le p r puisqu'en fait
les terrains ont été achetés les choses
sont en train d'être organisée et c'est
alors qu'il n'y a eu aucun débat au
parlement ni aucun débat avec les
citoyens et que c'est une décision qui
engage la nation pour des décennies qui
ne peut pas être prise à la légère sans
débat démocratique chantal jouanno c'est
vrai ça veut dire parce que là vous
réalisez est obligatoire
en fait la loi l'imposé mais pour autant
donc il ya eu d'évident donc il ya donc
il y aura débat où il ya eu des martin
si vous dites les
les locaux les sites ont déjà été
choisis dans la vie sans la loi pour
l'instant c'est ces fermetures de deux
réacteurs d'ici 2035 donc faire des
nouveaux rêves
si votre premier débat vous le faites
effectivement par exemple à penly sans
qu'ils aient préalablement un débat
général sur c'est quoi l'objectif quelle
est la place du nucléaire dans cet
objectif tout ce débat va se déverser
sur le premier repère et ça va être très
compliqué et effectivement on a déjà eu
ce débat sur flamanville les gens vont
nous dire mais si la décision est déjà
prise c'est un débat bidon donc ça va
radicaliser les positions il faut un
vrai débat sincère si souvent on parle
de sincérité dans les débats publics
faut vraiment décideurs soient prêts à
partager la décision a les clés après il
revient au parlement de décider d'accord
mais
mes buts quand même c'est que le
parlement soit clé la parole du public
dans les connaissances et puis peut-être
aussi par l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques y contribuer au débat
juste un mot sur les nerfs d'abord votre
présentation était parfaite la barre
dans votre type il est très bien c'était
tout à fait clair deuxièmement il ya
quand même beaucoup de régions dans le
monde qui vivent au charbon et on a
besoin d'apporter une réponse et qu'un
homme comme bill gates consacre des
sommes très importantes pour développer
des solutions industrialisable
répétitives et de dimensions modestes
pour éviter des effets de masse ça me
paraît très bon
l'enjeu essentiel est là je suis
d'accord l'enjeu essentiel c'est de
trouver de fermer ce qu'on appelle le
cycle du combustible la ddr faire en
sorte que je dirais pas indéfiniment
mais que d'une façon massive les le
combustible soit indéfiniment
réutilisées c'est ce qu'on appelle les
réacteurs à neutrons rapides
c'est-à-dire qu'ils peuvent réutiliser
les déchets du nucléaire il se trouve
que je suis vous savez on les gens
disent en général pas dans mon jardin
vous sait très bien ce que vous faites
mais maintenant mon jardin ma il se
trouve que je suis un élu qui après
avoir été ministre de l'industrie et mis
en oeuvre une loi socialiste leur
bataille sur la gestion des déchets
nucléaires a accepté d'accueillir des
déchets nucléaires forte activité non
pas dans mon jardin mais dans les deux
départements de la haute marne et de la
musque et je représente l'un d'entre eux
ce qui nous intéresse nous c'est le
progrès scientifique et nous voulons que
l'on ferme le cycle de combustible c'est
à dire faire en sorte que 90% du conduit
cible soit presque indéfiniment recyclé
on a perdu du temps en arrêtant
superphénix on relance avec des
nouvelles générations qui n'est pas
spécifiquement les nerfs parce que le
cmrc en effet de l'eau pressurisée comme
n'existe mais ce que l'on veut c'est des
réacteurs à neutrons rapides qui
permettent d'utiliser les
déchets indique je dirais pas
indéfiniment mais à la sab le mans bon
si on arrive à ça on progresse vraiment
parce que le nucléaire en effet deux
défauts premièrement dernier les déchets
ont été très long terme et deuxième
débat public neutraliser des espèces
mais excellent grâce à l'asn grâce à
lire et saine la france a un système qui
est très contrôlé la france et des
autres pays c'est pour ce à dire que le
nucléaire ne peut pas être universel ou
peut être appliquée que dans les bruits
responsable merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat doit
remercier toutes les équipes de public
sénat ici en régie à la rédaction c'est
toujours un bonheur de bosser avec vous
je vous dis à lundi